Alright, so this is now the Q in the equation, again.
Which again is one of these alphabased things. And, just to
be clear, I really do mean, you know, alpha sub t.
That we're, that were doing this over time. We're updating our
learning rates as we go. It's just, sometimes it's a little
irritating to put that, that there. But but yeah. So let's
imagine that we're doing that. We're, we're, we're using that same
kind of weighted process. Bumping the values around. So, what would,
based on what we just talked about,
Charles, what would this actually be computing?
>> Well, it would be computing the average value that you would get for
following, you know, kind of optimal policy
after you take this particular action. Yeah, that
it's, it's trying to go to this expected value and, and what is that
expected value. So the linearity of expectation
says that we can actually move the expectation
to break up, break up the sum using the expectation. So this,
the expected value of the reward is actually r of s. Mm-hm.
>> The gamma's going to come out because of linearity of expectation. ANd
then what we're left with is the expectation over all next dates of
the maximum estimated value of the estimated Q value of the next state.
But what is this distribution over S prime? It's the distribution that is
determeined by the transtiion function. SO it's this. Which is you know this.
So that's good. It's I'm kind of cheating though. Do you see how I'm cheating.
>> I think I know how you are cheating but tell me.
>> Well so when I told the story about this alpa arrow updating thing. I
said that it convergence to the expected value
of this quantity here. But this quantity here...
Since it's "Q hat", it's actually changing over time.
>> Right.
>> So this target is actually a moving target. It's changing over time. So we
can't quite do this analysis because the
first step is a little bit questionable. But
it turns out that there really is a theorem that this simple update rule, this
Q-learning update rule, this tiny little one
line of code, actually solves Markov decision processes.
>> Yeah.